black holes are the most powerful things
in the universe strong enough to rip
whole stars into atoms sized pieces well
this is scary enough they have an even
more powerful and dark property they
might delete the universe itself black
holes in a nutshell a black hole appears
when an extraordinary amount of matter
is concentrated in a tiny space at their
center gravity is almost infinitely
strong and whatever gets too close is
ripped into its elementary particles not
even light can escape black holes and so
we perceive them as spheres of blackness
if you were to fall into a black hole
nothing bad would happen until well
after you crossed its outer border the
event horizon you can imagine this as
swimming in a river that ends in an
enormous waterfall as you float along
imperceptibly the stream gets faster and
faster even if you can't see the
waterfall yet you could swim to safety
until without even noticing it you cross
the point of no return no matter how
fast you try to swim now the stream will
pull you towards certain death nothing
can escape a black hole waterfall once
it gets too close
this border completely separates black
holes from the rest of the universe we
can't access them unless we're willing
to never return so there's no way of
telling what's really going on inside
black holes but we have a few ideas
about what's going on right at their
very edges
black holes radiate their mass away like
a hot pot on a stove losing its water
esteem this is called Hawking radiation
black holes constantly lose an extremely
tiny amount of their mass a process
that's unbelievably slow it will take a
black hole with a mass of our Sun 10,000
billion billion billion billion billion
billion years to lose zero point zero
zero zero zero zero zero one percent of
its mass this is happening constantly
and unstoppably
and as it goes on it speeds up more and
more in the far far future when the last
star in the universe has been dead for
trillions of years black holes will
become tinier and tinier until they
evaporate and disappear leaving behind
just a bit of radiation but this is a
problem because in the process of
disappearing black holes might delete
something fundamental information - what
is information information is nothing
tangible it's typically understood as a
property of the arrangement of particles
what does this mean imagine a bunch of
carbon atoms arrange them in a certain
way and you get coal arrange them in a
different way and you get a diamond the
answers are the same what changes is the
information if we make this more complex
and add in a few more atoms we get a
banana change the arrangement of the
atoms and we get a squirrel the basic
building blocks of everything in the
universe are the same and don't care if
they're part of a bird or a rock or a
cup of coffee without information
everything in the universe would be the
same according to the theory of quantum
mechanics information is indestructible
it might change shape but it can never
be lost for example if you burn a piece
of paper you get ash that ash will never
become paper again but if you were able
to carefully collect every single carbon
atom in the ash and measured the exact
properties of the smoke and heat
radiating from the fire you could in
theory reconstruct the paper
the information of the paper is still in
the universe it's not lost it's just
hard to read if you could somehow
measure every single atom and particle
and wave of radiation in the universe
you could see and track every bit of
information there is hypothetically you
could see the entire history of the
universe right back to the Big Bang and
here
black holes trip us up information tells
us how things are different from each
other
and what used to be what black holes do
the opposite they take different things
and make them the same they destroy
information this creates the information
paradox and this is a serious problem
the information paradox it's fundamental
for all our laws of physics that
information can never be lost
existing not existing without
information everything is relative when
it comes to our understanding of reality
we need absolute how could we solve this
paradox there are a few possibilities
one information is lost irretrievably
and forever this means we have to nix
all our laws of physics throwing out a
lot of stuff that's worked very well so
far and to start from scratch what those
new laws of physics would look like or
what that means for us nobody knows this
is a little frightening but also kind of
exciting too information is hidden maybe
a little part of the black hole splits
often forms a baby universe the
information would be transferred into
this new weird place where we could
never observe or interact with it but
technically it would not be lost it's
like having a broken hard drive with all
your family photos that you could never
access sure it's nice that they've not
been deleted but also not very helpful
or maybe black holes don't disappear
completely after the end of their life
cycles but a little piece is left an
information diamond like a clown car
filled with an infinite amount of
information clowns but there's a third
option information is safe after all not
lost or hidden
perhaps we've just been looking at this
whole thing the wrong way we know that
black holes trap information and might
delete it later but we never thought
about what they do with it in the
meantime
we're two black holes store their
information cosmic housekeeping let's
create a black hole with dirty laundry
first we fill up a room with laundry
baskets the more laundry you want to
store the more baskets you put in the
room but at some point every single
basket is full and the room is
completely stacked not a single extra
sock fits in the room is at maximum
capacity but if we still squeeze the
sock in with a lot of energy and
violence the room collapses in on itself
and forms a black hole but the capacity
of the room itself has not changed
fitting in more stuff for information is
still impossible so what happens if we
throw more laundry into it the room
itself gets a little bit bigger to make
space for the new information it turns
out a black hole grows its surface by a
tiny pixel for each bit of information
we throw into it in a nutshell more
information means more surface area the
information gets painted on the surface
similar to what happens when we throw a
stone into a pond after the stone sinks
to the bottom we can't see it anymore
but we can tell that something went in
from the ripples on the surface of the
pond even the smallest black hole can
store more information on its surface
than all the data ever produced in human
history they do this by storing
information in a type of pixel that is
unbelievably tiny black holes are the
ultimate hard drive this is a bit like
taking a paper bag and turning it into
an e-book to things that look completely
different but their content is the same
it's just encoded and memorized in
another way
black holes swallowing stars and planets
is a bit like transferring a whole
library onto an e-reader
this solution is called the holographic
principle but if it's correct then
everything we thought we knew about the
universe is wrong the universe is a
hologram if information is actually
stored on the boundary of a black hole
the Hawking radiation has a chance of
learning about the information encoded
there and can carry it away so
information is not lost when black holes
fade away
and we do not need to redo physics the
information paradox is resolved but we
still have to change our understanding
of reality in a fundamental way if
everything that falls into the black
hole is stored on its event horizon that
basically means that three-dimensional
stuff is encoded on a flat surface
we have a name for this a hologram a
hologram is like a 3d photo a flat piece
of plastic that encodes a
three-dimensional image a black hole is
like a hologram
because everything inside it is encoded
on its event horizon a person inside a
black hole would experience their usual
three-dimensional life but for us on the
outside they are flattened images on the
surface of the black hole the
consequence of this is counterintuitive
but stay with us for a moment
black holes are very extreme objects but
they're still bound to the same rules as
everything else so if this crazy qu
ality between 2d and 3d works for black
holes then it might work for the whole
universe and you in it since a person
inside a black hole would not realize
that they're encoded on a flat surface
we might share the same fate you really
might be stretched over a flat screen at
the end of the universe
the science behind this is complicated
and really weird with toy universes to
play with string theory and a lot of
mass we'll talk about this more in
another video regardless of what the
true nature of the universe really is we
just know that it's strange and
complicated and we have to do a lot more
physics to understand it but black holes
might be key to understanding the nature
of reality itself
this video was supported by the Swiss
National Science Foundation and realized
with the scientific advice of Alessandro
Swan drainie